time now for our Bloomberg quick take
where we provide context and background
on issues of interest the auto industry
seems to be hurtling headlong into an
era when cars drive themselves it may
sound futuristic but parts of it are
already here the robots are easing us
out of the driver's seat bit by bit
here's the situation earlier this year
US government proposed spending four
billion dollars over ten years on
research and infrastructure to promote
driverless cars in September the
government laid out a regulatory path
for automakers to win approval for
putting them on the road all the makers
and technology companies are partnering
up in order to make this a reality
Google and Fiat Chrysler are teaming up
to develop about 100 self-driving
minivans while BMW is collaborating with
Intel and mobile ID GM is investing in
lifts and is developing a fleet of robot
taxis here's the background the dream of
a self-driving car first appeared in the
pages of science fiction and then in the
General Motors futurama display at the
1939 World's Fair consumers got their
first taste of auto pilot in the 1990s
when automakers began offering adaptive
cruise control Google accelerated the
pace of development by logging more than
2 million miles testing its driverless
cars on Silicon Valley roads here's the
argument there are a few laws on the
books requiring drivers to keep their
hands on the wheel because no one
imagined that would ever be an issue
more broadly there is the ethical
dilemma of turning over decision-making
power to a robot in a life-or-death
situation the question of liability also
remains unanswered automakers do have to
yet design a connected car as well that
can't be hacked that raises security
concerns and dystopian scenarios of
robot cars run amok yet to us regulators
and others driverless cars could save
thousands of lives since driver error is
blamed in ninety-four percent of crashes